we begin with this here at 6 30 an
animal cruelty investigation up in north
las vegas is sparking outrage this
morning
one animal rights group will rally later
today they are demanding felony charges
now
after the death of a dog hector mejia
live outside city hall with more on this
story good morning hector
hey there alex good morning and this
will be the meeting spot for the local
activists at three o'clock in the
afternoon and that's because there's a
city council meeting scheduled today
and they hope city council members can
hear them out
we first told you about the story about
a week ago a video surfaced
showing a dog having a hard time
breathing while chained outside under
the hot summer sun
at a home in north las vegas activists
say their calls to help the dog
10 year old lily went ignored until it
was way too late
the neighbor claims they emailed north
las vegas animal control four days in a
row
the group nevada voters for animals now
wants felony cruelty charges
filed against the owner last week we
talked with a woman with a group
not only do we write the laws i mean
really laws are what they're words on
paper
we are actually also out there trying to
ensure that the laws are enforced
a petition is making the rounds online
calling for justice for the dog it now
has close to 9
000 signatures we've learned north las
vegas police did open
an animal cruelty investigation that is
now
going over to the city attorney's office
we'll let you know what happens
reporting live from north las vegas this
morning hector mejia
8 news now